oh my God Alex now wasn't your show
supposed to run for like a limited time
yeah it was supposed to run for three
weeks uh Off-Broadway and uh and it's
been a beautiful we ran for like nine
months which was crazy
[Applause]
for nine months and then that show ends
up getting chosen to go on the Broadway
stage yeah it's the craziest coolest
most wonderful most surreal experience
of my entire life so I mean it
Alex is
just something that really talks
talks maybe you have people that don't
like you because of certain reasons I
should yeah I went to I'm I'm an
orthodox Jew and I went to this meeting
of white nationalists in Queens and
eventually what a what a fun reaction
from you already yeah fantastic and
eventually one of them's like sorry but
this guy's a Jew and I'm like damage you
and like that's what the show is about
basically actually I basically just
given away the whole show but yeah like
that's what happens no I'm glad you gave
it the context because it does not give
the show away and it made me ball my
eyes out yeah Drew's there she's crying
I'm like oh my god did I upset her and
she was like
it was it was uh it was really sweet but
yeah people like really reacted to the
show in a way that's like taking me by
surprise in such in such lovely ways and
so many of my heroes have come to see it
which has been so cool which um let's
see who's come to see your show because
also people are saying that you're like
the new Seinfeld how do you feel about
that I mean Seinfeld came to the show
and I don't think Seinfeld would say
that honestly so I mean yeah that was
that was uh when Jerry came to see it
which was so cool and afterwards I asked
him for I was like do you have any notes
and he was like I don't have any notes
and I was like what are you like you're
gonna get in the car and look at Jessica
and be like I like that butt and he went
okay I've got one no it's great and he
gave me the and he gave me the note and
Steve Martin when Steve Martin came I
was the these are the people going to
see Alex's show yeah
what was his reaction Steve was really
he was so nice and he offered uh he
offered a he was he offered like a
little joke so if you don't like the
show uh it's co-written by Steve Martin
so you remember yeah and Jerry Seinfeld
so
um now there's a fever pitch connection
oh my God you like wrote for the red
side when I was a kid I I wrote on uh I
wrote for the Red Sox for a couple years
I was like a speechwriter and I wrote
the Red Sox kids newsletter that is the
cutest thing ever it's really really
really crazy and um and one of my
assignments was I covered the fever
pitch Premiere yes and so when I was 16
we met at the fever Bridge Premiere I
was like a child I don't think I looked
at you at all like I was like I was
looking at my shoes like I owed it money
like it was just like
I was so nervous and I had no social
skills so like why don't we just have
this kid who's never met a single person
outside of his synagogue or his school
you know uh interview like Jimmy Fallon
and uh and Drew Barrymore okay well
there was oh a magazine a story like you
you sent our producer a magazine no I
didn't send your produce this producer
came up to me I was standing by myself
that's a fever pitch it's like the most
vivid memory of my life he went hey
little kid and I I had this
Entertainment Weekly with you and uh and
one of the Red Sox players I think
Johnny Damon and Jimmy Fallon on the
cover and my mom said you're going to
the viewer Premiere can you get
them to sign it and I was like well I
was gonna ask uh Jimmy and Drew to sign
this uh this magazine for my mom and
he's like I'll get it signed and he took
the magazine and he never gave it back
to me and then didn't you send it I sent
him an email I sent him a follow-up
email
why are you showing the email like you
said sure this is Alex
it's the little kid
from fever pitch from here thanks so
much for taking that Entertainment
Weekly for me uh let me know if you get
the chance for Drew to sign it it would
be a total honor uh I was 16 years old
Joe okay
and I looked like I was 11 and no he
never sent it did he true so I got you
one oh my God
[Applause]
that's so nice oh my God this is so
sweet
[Applause]
Alex's show Just For Us is making a
strawberry
Beckett catch it if you can we'll be
right back
[Music]
foreign